that's not the plan
so when you like because listen
obviously you have been
you have been on in some sort of
Spotlight due to your you know
relationship with blue over the last you
know three or four years right yeah
we've seen a lot of drama a lot of
craziness you put your paws on people
um
who I put my clothes on I feel like I
just just
would diving so I don't know it could be
wrong I could yeah
um but I'm curious let's just get back
to the beginning how did you guys
initially meet up because you were like
baby mama Uno right right so you're the
first one
you're the OG the OG
um how did you guys do that let's take
it back how did you guys first meet uh
we went to high school together okay in
high school
and uh was this one he was playing
football yeah a little football star or
whatever so you're the football star and
then you got like do you guys go to prom
together yeah yeah we went to yours yeah
oh so you guys did go to prom yeah oh
nice how was prom did you guys have sex
in prom
well in and out High uh and so give me
kind of because for you like
um
there's been so much
controversy regarding Blues
relationships in general yeah period
um I feel like you've you know you had
to have dealt with a lot of
difficult situations to pay to pay
attention to online or not pay attention
to like do you land a lot of the
comments or a lot of the
stuff people say about you maybe a
relationship because obviously you have
a kid like right yeah
um I don't let it bother me I mean I
think because like I know what it is in
real life it's kind of like the internet
just they see one little 25 and they
make it into like 110 so I don't I don't
let what they say bother me
um blue for you is this MILF music thing
a real thing definitely I think I think
we'll get more talent coming in based
off her
impression you know so in order to be on
your new label you have to have child
yeah you gotta have a kid like what's
the object we're audition Yeah Baby
Daddy has to be a reference like he
asked about you so it doesn't have to be
your baby Mama's only on MILF music it
could be anybody who's got children yeah
yeah definitely can you be pregnant yeah
yeah what if someone's just expecting
are you pregnant you could be okay so
that qualifies
so all we got to know is you got you got
something to lose you know you got
something to live for you got something
to die for you're not just like taking
advantage of the situation so you
obviously have been in relationships
with uh women who you've started their
rap careers obviously Christians did
just performed the other night I saw her
she fell I mean I hope she's all right
um
how did you start rapping like did you
convince her or what like
okay so um
one day I just came I walked in the
house and she was like let me try it
like okay he didn't just walk in we were
we were drinking it wasn't like it was
just like hey how you doing okay
no I mean yeah he came over one day we
was drinking and I was just like put me
in like let's go and then he was like
for real I'm like yeah let's see like
how it goes how long ago was that
so for you do you kind of see like the
like okay because we can't like the
elephant in the room is krishan's a star
right she's huge and you I mean that's a
lot to do with you obviously right do
you see that and say hey I could do that
but I could do it better oh
I mean there's no traffic if you're in
your own lane like I'm not really like
in a competition with nobody
stop that [__]
no I'm just saying I'm not in a country
with nobody it wasn't like that at all I
don't know she's always been a fan of
music though right I like pay attention
to more artists but she never like told
me get me so it was like when I heard it
I was like so it's like the way I see is
like say if I'm the dope man right I'm
never gonna like insist on you getting
in the game and selling dope but if you
come to me like yeah man I want to get
some money
here yeah
here take this though let me see what
you do today so what's that kind of like
I was like okay I was surprised when she
asked me I was like oh yeah